all right so I am here with Senator John
McCain and you are in DC this is an
important day for DC for Iowa for the
entire country so my first question are
you a betting man and who's your money
on
I am I am a betting man and I since I've
been consistently wrong at every turn in
this most incredible scenario I figure I
there's no sense in sending bad money
after good all right fair enough
so what what is DC like on a day like
today I mean we've been waiting for the
Iowa caucuses it seems like we've been
waiting for this thing for like three
years but what's the general feeling in
DC on a day like this I think the
general feeling in DC is bewilderment
that we have seen the rise of a course
Cruz and Trump on one side and Bernie
Sanders on the other and none of that of
course was predicted six months ago no
matter who you talk to and perhaps it's
because we underestimated the anger and
dissatisfaction level out there places
like the cornfields of Iowa yeah so for
someone like you that's considered more
now I think more as an establishment guy
although when you've run in the past you
were sort of anti-establishment what
what do you make of the feeling that's
in the country that again we're in an
anti-establishment year well first of
all you know I'm entertained that that I
was established and I'm the
establishment well I
nickname was the Maverick as you know
for a long time as a reformer but you
know life isn't fair Jack Kennedy said
like I think that that we've failed to
appreciate the fact that millions of
Americans have stopped looking for work
that there is been a very slow or
non-existent recovery at least in the
view of middle-income Americans which
actually are shrinking and we also see
this fear
if that's the word or concern about
illegal immigration and particularly
older white males that see what they
think is an erosion of the traditional
makeup of America and of course Trump
and Cruz have played to all of these
fears look we have great challenges in
the world and we need a new leader in my
view very badly who will not lead from
behind but lead from in front but this
the fact is America is still the
greatest nation on earth and but if
you're a individual who lost their job
during the recession and have gotten
either a much lower paying job or still
out of work that really doesn't matter
and Trump has appealed to that and
Sanders has appealed to that yeah just a
small example but six weeks ago I think
it was now Bernie Sanders came to Tucson
Arizona 13,000 people showed up my
friend I could not draw 13,000 people in
Tucson Arizona if I paid him to attend
right so there's there's a they're both
Sanders and Trump and Cruz have tapped
this unhappiness this frustration that
that people feel and it's being
manifested now but could I just add one
additional points or I think to a large
degree that neither Trump or Cruz but
particularly Trump have been forced to
ask the tough to answer the tough
questions that should be asked yesterday
I was watching one of the sunday shows
that Trump was on and and they were
talking about Trump said repeal and
replace Obamacare and the questioner who
I happen to be an admirer of said well
how are you going to do that he said I
will sit down and negotiate with the
hospitals and the providers that that's
not in the answer right that's not how
it works yeah and and you know how
are going to deport 11 million people
how do you do that those are legitimate
questions that are not being asked by
the media than in every campaign I've
been involved in the tough questions
have been asked and so part of this
frankly part of this frankly I blame on
the media so what do you make of that
because this is one of the things we
talk about on this show all the time
that our media right now seems like
they're so in bed with the campaign's
the network's you know there's this line
that's very blended between
the networks and who's getting what
question and it seems like if you ask
more of a softball question you're going
to get the opportunity to ask more
question so what do we do about that and
I don't know because he is sort of broke
already broken all the rules have you
ever heard of a presidential candidate
that is a that calls in to a Sunday show
talk-show right not right you ever have
you ever heard of one who blatantly
attacks a very legitimate and respected
journalist in the case of megyn kelly
have you ever seen a candidate in the
case of Cruz who was virtually reversed
himself on every major national security
issue
so there's does anybody anymore
read these various publications that are
fact checkers there's four four no Chios
Oh last time so it but it is what it is
and I still have faith and confidence in
American voters and on both sides of the
aisle and and so I will do what I can to
to conduct my own campaign and encourage
people to get out and invoke many of
those who generally don't do so all
right well I don't want to get totally
bogged down in the election because I
want to talk about some of the issues
that have been important to you over the
years but one more thing on this when
you watch this do you think oh man this
this is the year that I should have
jumped in because I would be up there as
as the same candidate as the guy that
really would be sort of crossing line
and bringing people together I know I
feel nostalgia for ah New Hampshire
because I love New Hampshire and of
course I some wonderful experiences
there but very honestly I'm not sure
that I would be doing well in this kind
of environment I just I just I'm not
sure that I would because they're the
people are not that I don't know I know
this that we're talking about trivia
when and building walls with Mexico when
the world is on fire
yeah and that of course is one thing
that I regret if I had been running
again I guarantee you that would have
been what I'm what I'm talking about and
I think that's what most Americans would
like to hear about because it's now the
number one or number two issue and I can
assure you there will be more attacks on
the United States of America between now
and November all right so I want to get
to that and I think that's really sort
of your wheelhouse stuff so to end the
election portion we should note that in
the Iowa caucus in 2007 you actually
came in fourth and then you still went
on to win the nomination so people
shouldn't get too caught up in the in
the daily minutia of all of this right I
don't think so but again you know in
previous elections Iowa caucus has sort
of been put in the context of what it is
there's not been a I think George W Bush
won both but other than that the people
who have won have quickly the Iowa
caucuses have quickly faded right but it
seems that the Iowa caucus is now have
taken on a greater significance not so
much it's of caucuses but because it
seems to be this fight of Trump and Cruz
versus all the others which then I think
is magnified the the impact of the Iowa
caucuses more than in any time in the
past sure all right so before we jump
into some foreign policy stuff
you know so much of this campaign
because of Bernie has been about money
in politics and I think people forget
that you were fighting to get money out
of politics a long time ago there used
to be something called the
mccain-feingold act in 2002 that you
guys pass and the whole idea was to get
money out of politics or at least you
know regulate it in some way that would
make sense does that seem like a whole
other lifetime ago for you at this point
because now we have more money in than
ever in the super PACs and obviously
everyone knows about the citizens united
Supreme Court decision and all that I
think it's clear indication that the
chickens have come home to roost when
you see that Ted Cruz for example got
what was it fifteen million dollars each
from two individuals where you see
hundreds of millions of dollars
Washington around a lot of it
untraceable all I can do assure you of
Dave is that there will be a scandal
yeah that scandal will probably have to
do with foreign money there is too much
unaccounted for money washing around and
the whole fundamental rationale why the
of the Supreme Court when they turn down
McCain Feingold when citizens unit with
citizens united is that money is free
speech well I have a vault money is
speech I've always disagreed with that
because then that means that people that
are incredibly wealthy like these people
that are funding campaigns are they're
they're they can speak more loudly than
the average citizen so I and it is
peopled this is a logical result of the
Supreme Court decision which I predicted
and it's going to get worse before it
gets better
yeah and isn't it a two-fold problem
because now not only is money going to
the super PACs which supposedly aren't
coordinated with the campaign's but I
find that a little hard to believe but
it's that and then also the traditional
money's that campaigns got are actually
going to the super PACs so then the
campaign's probably have to go and find
money other ways to so it's just like a
completion of problems right yeah and
when you have one individual giving
fifteen million dollars
I think it's obvious one of the reasons
why there has not been a greater
attrition so far although we may see it
after Iowa and New Hampshire a week
later is because they've had these
additional funds which has kept them in
the race that they're able to afford the
staff and the you know all the expenses
of a presidential campaign so it has had
many many random ramifications and none
of them that I've seen have been good
for the country
yeah do you think that the the money
directly leads to decisions being made
like I understand that it helps keep
staff on and it keeps the operation
going and all that kind of stuff but do
you think at the end of the day that it
genuinely leads politicians congressmen
senators presidential candidates to
actually making decisions in a certain
way it's hard for me to make that kind
of a judgment but I do know that there
are certain things that happen around
here that clearly have the influence of
some of the major interests financial
interests and but but I see that for
example we just added in a time of
really short funds for defense I just
saw in this omnibus appropriations bill
that we passed with about 48 hours
notice with no amendments a 225 million
dollar ship made in Mobile Alabama put
in in the middle of the night by guess
who the senator senator Shelby of
Alabama that is a ship that the Navy
that's a second ship he's put in at 225
million dollars each which the Navy has
said
they needed one nor use so there's still
a lot of the old-fashioned earmarking
and pork barreling going on yeah well my
point yeah I do what do they say the
government why buy one when you can
build two at twice the price right right
and it's one of the reasons why you see
the cynicism that a lot of Americans
have when they read about two hundred
and twenty five million dollars of their
tax dollars going to build a ship that
the Navy neither wants nor needs then of
course of course they're cynical yeah
and then of course you have these
tremendous cost overruns associated with
some of our weapon systems which are a
national scandal the USS Gerald r Ford
was supposed to cost ten billion dollars
it ended up that's a aircraft carrier so
it ended up costing twelve billion
dollars and you know there's only one
place in America where they make our
craft carriers it's it's it's
disgraceful yeah all right so we get the
money situation and it doesn't seem to
be getting better but but we shall see
so let's let's move on to foreign policy
because I think this is you know
especially an area of your expertise and
I think it's partly as you just said a
moment ago the world seems like it's on
fire right now and I think part of it is
that people both internationally and
domestically we don't know what America
is anymore I feel like our policy is no
longer we're either in the Middle East
or we're not in the Middle East we're
watching Isis grow you know we don't
have a congressional declaration of war
are we is this as big of a mess as it
appears to be well I will freely admit
to being very upset and somewhat
partisan on this issue I will admit to
that but I believe that I am correct in
that Lindsey Graham and I predicted
everything that has happened and I wish
we had been wrong when we there's three
seminal events one when we pulled all
our troops out of Iraq which we didn't
have to do claiming that there had to be
a Status of Forces Agreement by the way
there's about 4,000 back in without a
Status of Forces Agreement pulling all
of them out
left Iraq prey to the Shiites and now
the dominant force in Iraq is is the
Iranians the second was the when the
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
Secretary of Defense Panetta and head of
CIA then Dave General David Petraeus
recommended arming and equipping the
Free Syrian Army at that time the
president was saying it's not a matter
of whether Bashar Assad Falls it's a
matter of when when the president turned
that down that basically gave a green
light to the Iranians Hezbollah and now
the Russians to intervene third was of
course the famous red line the president
said he would take military action if
the Syrians used chemical weapons and
they did and after committing to doing
so he decided not to that sent a message
around the world that the United States
word is is not valued and that's why you
see the Saudis and other Gulf countries
and others going their own way because
they no longer have any confidence in
the United States meanwhile we've
watched the Chinese filling Islands and
build runways and gross violation of
national law we watch Vladimir Putin
dismember the Ukraine and by the way in
a month or so you will see in increased
activities military activities by the
Russians in eastern Ukraine and so the
world is and then now in case you missed
it we now are going to attack Isis guess
we're in Afghanistan and the president
still commenced reducing the troop
numbers and Isis is metastasizing
throughout the Middle East they're now
in Libya of course we're in Afghanistan
they're springing up everywhere and they
now have for the first time in history a
terrorist state in Raqqa so things are
very bad and and it's a direct result of
them failure of American leadership and
a belief on the part of President Obama
that with a new relationship with Iran
that it would be like Nixon to
and their behavior would be different
and I can't tell you as a fourth is a
four generation Navy family my
grandfather my father me and my son who
is a naval officer how absolutely
ashamed and outraged I am about them
putting American sailors on their knees
with their hands clasped behind their
necks and now in the latest of course
the the Ayatollah awarded medals to the
to those that did it for quote capturing
Americans in gross violation of all
international law and the thing that
makes me furious is that the
vice-president itíd States the Secretary
of State and the Secretary of Defense
all praised the Iranians because they
release them I mean it is it is
unbelievable
it is it is it is so infuriating that it
makes me it makes me so mad but it also
makes me sad yeah so there there's a lot
there I want to back up to the red line
though because I can really sense from
from the tone with which you're saying
it that that was the moment really where
people felt that America's word no
longer mattered so on when that happened
like was your phone ringing off the hook
I mean we're Pete were the Saudis or the
Kuwaiti s or the Jordanians or whoever
the Israelis were they calling you and
saying what is going on here I mean
really is this actually happening yes
and let me just give you a brief
anecdote the president called me and
Lindsey Graham over to the White House
in the Oval Office he said I'm going to
act I'm going to degrade Bashar Assad
I'm going to upgrade the Free Syrian
Army I'm going to change the momentum on
the battlefield we will be commencing
operations Lindsey and I went out on
driveway front of the median said were
with the president all the way they have
crossed the red line a week later I was
sitting in my office and watched on CNN
as the president announced it after all
we were not and you know the Saudis had
planes on runways ready to attack Syria
when they found out on CNN as well and
so this
this was a defining moment that's why
the Saudis decide to go into Yemen on
their own that's why the Saudis and
other Gulf countries are acting on on
their own this is why the foreign
minister of one of the Gulf countries
told me we think it's better to be
America's enemy than its friend so it
the American credibility took a gigantic
blow as you and so they're they're going
their own way these countries are yeah
is this the ultimate irony sort of
American power at least as it stands in
2016 that when we do things there's this
immediate feeling in the international
community that we're always going at it
alone and we're always doing whatever we
want and then when we don't do things
that actually things seemingly get worse
so we're sort of in an old eye situation
here right but I think the most
important thing aspect this is that when
America commits to a course of action
mm-hmm and then backs off of it that is
the most damaging of all it would been
far better never to say a word about
Bashar Assad slaughter using chemical
weapons by the way I keep on my desk
those pictures that were smuggled out of
all those dead children killed by the
sarin gas but anyway so it's it's a it
the worst of all worlds is when the
world's superpower commits to a course
of action and then doesn't could I just
say it's a toe line that George Shultz
used to say is Marine Corps drill
instructor told him that never point a
weapon at someone unless you're ready to
pull the trigger yeah well that that's
sort of a perfect segue to what I wanted
to ask you about next which is the Kurds
because you've maintained a relationship
with the Kurds we've been talking about
the Kurds on this show a little bit and
I feel like the the Kurdish situation
you know these thirty million people
that are sort of spread across Iraq and
Syria and Turkey that are trying to get
a state that are actually fighting Isis
on the ground while being bombed by a
NATO ally Turkey and a hole in their you
know fighting Isis and it's just this
big mess what what can we do for the
Kurds as Americans
and to sort of get our government to
back the Kurds more because they're
there cause seems so just to me and we
don't talk about it a couple points one
is that the Kurds are the only effective
fighting force as you know in the region
and we never could have taken kobani
back or some of the successes we've
enjoyed second of all they are out of
money they are not being able to pay
their forces a lot of it has to do the
price of a way a lot of it has do the
expenses of their military operations
but we got to get them money and we got
to do it quickly third of all the Turks
are as afraid of a of a Kurdish nation
as much as they are of Isis or Bashar
Assad by the way they view Bashar Assad
is a far greater enemy than they do Isis
which is why we haven't seen more
cooperation between the Turks and us and
of course the Turks continue to view the
PKK it gets really complicated but the
PKK is a terrorist organization but
there's other Kurdish or organs that are
not terrorists and they have been very
effective fighting force but right now
they haven't got the weaponry they need
and most of all they haven't got the
money that they need in order to
maintain the level of operations they're
in a severe economic crisis but they are
great fighters they are great friends
they are wonderful people I have such a
respect and affection for the Kurds I
can't exaggerate it yeah well that's why
I've wanted to talk about them more
because I you know I see female fighters
you know on the ground and they're
they're trying to build a state and
they're not getting the support is some
of that though because of our nature of
our relationship with Turkey I mean we
know that Turkey has been letting Isis
fighters through Europe into Syria we
know the turkeys fighting the Kurds and
yet Turkey obviously is a NATO ally and
all that so we're in a weird position
with the with the Kurds because of
turkey right you know but
Herta one has consolidated his position
he is on the road to being a dictator he
obviously he's overturned the election
that put the opposition into a majority
and he is trying to consolidate
basically what is a dictatorship and we
need to use the base at Incirlik for our
operations and I'm glad they allowed
such a thing but I also think that he's
partially right and when he says that
Bashar Assad is a greater threat to the
region with its alliance with Iran and
with Russia then Isis is although then
he wants us to fight both Isis as well
as as Bashar Assad and of course John
Kerry keeps keeps his bizarre behavior
thereby legitimizing Bashar Assad's
continued slaughter of 250,000 people
and millions of refugees by the way I
have the greatest sympathy for the
Europeans as they grapple with this
refugee issue I have great sympathy for
the refugees themselves but they're
addressing the end of the chain not the
beginning if it would not for Bashar
Assad you would not see these millions
of refugees and the Europeans have sat
by and watched Bashar Assad slaughter
his own people and basically did nothing
so they are paying the price of inaction
and some of this is very reminiscent of
the 1930s yeah well it seems we're stuck
between Assad and Isis and as you're
saying there's so many complex issues
here in so many sides that people don't
know what to do I know I have to let you
go so I want to ask you one thing
let's give me something that on the
hopeful side of all this because I know
this is this is sort of it's powerful
stuff it can be depressing and it feels
overwhelming and I think especially in
an election year it all gets ramped up
to the point where people don't know
what's going on so what do you take that
that can make people feel good about all
this well
with the right leadership America's
possibilities and probabilities are
unlimited we're now energy independent
you're not old enough but I am too
remember waiting in gas lines for hours
and to get five gallons of gas because
OPEC had their hand on the energy
throttle and that can never happen again
in fact if we did the right thing we
could export our natural gas that is now
being flared in the North Dakota oil
fields and get it to the living rooms of
Kev and other countries in Eastern
Europe so they wouldn't be dependent on
Russian energy manufacturing jobs are
staying and improving they're not big
employers because of automation and
technology but they are staying and many
of them are coming back third of all
this device that you and I carry around
all the time
unfortunately it seems to get bigger and
heavier is changing the world it's
changing the flow of information and
knowledge and there's a dark side to it
the cloak of anonymity and all of that
effect I see it in tweets to me every
day but overall overall this technology
correct could I just say is changing the
world and all of it for the better
you cannot repress and oppress people
when they have access to information and
knowledge over time and all of that is
not made in China it's not made in
Europe it's not invented anyplace but
the United States of America so I'm very
hopeful about our future yeah well I
love that as our as our parting words so
it's been a pleasure talking to you I
hope we can do this in person next time
you're in our sunny city of Los Angeles
I will look forward to doing a Dave
thanks a lot
all right thanks sir
you